and it's overreaction Monday Ridge so
what are you overreacting to what am I
overreacting to I think one way to
overreact is no I think that Seattle is
in deep trouble I think they'll find
themselves I think they're there Ricky
running back is going to take the reins
at some point and that Green Bay defense
just looked terrific I still believe in
Seattle the Giants you have to wait
until Odell gets back in there to Tate a
panic button there I am genuinely
concerned about New England they've
never won a Super Bowl without a bye
week and that team doesn't look like a
bye week team to me defensively and that
that that would concern me if I'm a
Patriots fan that that they're going to
have to play four playoff games to win a
Super Bowl like every like pedestrian
NFL teams would have to do so those are
some concerns
the Texans definitely concerned me
because you know Bill O'Brien once again
decided to go with somebody that he he
decided at halftime wasn't his starting
quarterback anymore but Deshawn Watson's
very talented a short week might not be
the best time to throw him in the mix
maybe if he even if he is hobbled too so
those would be the genuine ones well I
would agree though that that me also
that the Rams and the Colts game is
indicative I think the Rams do look like
a real offense I I think that that
Cooper cup is a genuine rookie threat
and Todd Gurley looked like the rookie
Todd Gurley and and golf definitely
looked far more professional ready than
before and the Colts are that bad
if I'm if I'm them I'm not putting
Andrew Luck in there period why in the
world would you have him back from
shoulder surgery and put him behind that
offensive line no no chance
I find them I would until I see better
line play he's stuck on the sidelines
yeah it might be strategic that you keep
Andrew Luck out I thought the same thing
if he's out for a couple more weeks and
they're not winning I I don't know if I
run the risk of putting him in there
behind that offensive one is there who
surprised you the most though if if I
looked at the Tennessee and Oakland game
how good Oakland was or the Tennessee
who looks like they're a playoff team
did not look inspired when they're
facing Oakland no I thought you know for
a team that that took a nice step
forward last year and have in my mind
all the pieces for their coach to come
out and say we're gonna go on so I click
to start the game and then say
afterwards were at halftime at what you
know we wanted to steal a possession
it's like what what the hell message
does that send to your team that one was
a complete head scratcher
I mean go out there play defense get the
ball back and and play football it's the
2017 season you know the fans are fired
up they were throwing catfish all summer
long you know they have that
championship feeling in that town about
one I couldn't believe and DeMarco
Murray looked a little tentative to me
maybe you'll end up seeing Derek Henry a
little bit more yeah
but they take on the team with the true
surprise though DP they've got to go to
Jackson Hole next week and the first
place Jaguars are first place Jaguars
however you say it
that defense looked to be no joke
yesterday let me go back to the Texans
who faced that defense and I'm surprised
at Bill O'Brien after a half and maybe
what 11 passes with Tom savage decided
oh okay now I'm going to make a change
here like that to me is mind-boggling
that it was that tenuous that fragile
that you're gonna go man if I don't see
what I want to see in the first half I'm
taking you out if that's the case why
were you starting tom savage in the
first place if the hook was gonna be
that quick I am completely lost up with
you I don't know why does Shaun Watson
wasn't the weak one starter for real
except for the fact that you know Savage
may have looked to look
in training camp and DeAndre Hopkins was
putting his chips in the in the in the
savage pile which is interesting because
of the Clemson connection with deshaun
Watson
yeah but if you're moving up to get
somebody and you have questions at the
quarterback position you got to start
him he's dynamic he's he's a leader on
if he's if he's healthy coming out of
that game which is a question then I
think today you'll hear that this sean
watson starts Thursday night
he's Rich Eisen NFL Network NFL Network
we'll have that game on Thursday night
it's the Texans and the Bengals the
Cowboys game what stood out how horrible
the Giants looked offensively and they
said is it really Odell Beckham like the
Jenga piece which is what I've heard him
being described as and they for the
offense you take him out and the whole
rest of it falls apart I mean I could
not believe that that they couldn't do a
darn thing and then when they did it was
you know I don't know other way to put
it like one of those maddening Andy Reid
Eagles slash Chiefs offenses up until
this past week where it takes 15 plays
to go 80 yards and you settle for three
that defense looks to be as good as
advertised
again they held the Cowboys with that
offense in that building to just 16
points so if I'm the Giants I take a
good part of that away but that offense
looked brutal and the offensive line has
no ability to protect Eli with no run
game I don't care how Eli can can can
play the game no quarterback can handle
that and Dallas I mean as long as his he
kill Elliott is going to stay playing
and despite the appeal that was filed
today it sure sounds like he's going to
play a long time if not the whole season
then they're a legit Super Bowl
contender certainly if Jaylon Smith
looked as good as he did with Sean Lee
who's all over the place and that so
again I just need to see them against an
offensive line that's a lot better than
than the Giants before I buy it and
they'll take on Denver next week we
always embrace a football cliche every
year the start of every year member
taking the top off the defense 2016 you
had to take the top off
fence there we have the football cliche
of 2017 if you're ready I am please can
you guess what the football cliche that
every analyst must say hmm no I'm
totally all ears what do you got set the
edge now why would that be 2017 there
there's they've been setting edges for
quite some time but but it's mandatory
that you have to set you have to set the
edge rich you have to zoom the edge is
that what I'm saying on Thursday night
of during the readings I think when you
turn to mooch say well mooch they have
to set the edge tonight don't they the
Texans do or how about this Michael
Irvin's at the end of the set and he's
setting the edge like that Mike you're
at the edge of the he's setting it he
sets the s40 nobody can get nobody
he's containing he can't break contain
me Michael Irvin so we had to take the
top off the defense remember then three
technique three technique was a big one
too
a couple years ago yeah oh yeah and just
be out in front of the curve here that
you're gonna set the edge on Thursday
night well Romo dropped the term cross
dog a lot during the Titans Raiders game
what do you think of his performance I
thought he was great
and I knew I thought he was terrific you
did you signed on him early yeah I
remember you saying it you'd heard great
time I thought you said he's got a tall
he's likable and the only concern was
was he could he be concise can he says
points quickly enough he even I think
even God and Nance's grill a couple
times and so I thought he was great he
was really enthusiastic like you can
scream roll tape at the truck because
he's so excited about a four wide a
situation that went well for Derek Carr
and he made the right decision like you
could feel it from I thought he was I
thought he was great I really did better
but explain this to me I I would never
be a network exec
but I would have put Romo in studio to
take advantage of him there I I know
that we all have that number one team
we're lucky with Al Michaels and Cris
Collinsworth who become the fabric of
the game this is different though it's
rare when you find a team like that that
is is immersed in there it's integrated
into the game Nance and Romo I thought
had a great debut but I get more I get
more out of Romo with his looks his
opinions I can use him pregame for an
hour I got half time I got post it just
feels like I would get more out of him
nationwide than I would with a Raiders
Titans game in week 1 well you're just
assuming as well that he would have
wanted to do that he just again the
passion that he had the energy that he
exude 'add yeah over over he was like
geeking out over sets and and defensive
looks I think he just wanted to be
personally I mean I haven't spoken him
about it yet but you know that he just I
think he just wants to be a game sight
you know as opposed to sitting in his
studio and watching and that's that's as
close as you're going to get without
playing and it felt like he was saying
to you as a quarterback I would say here
comes his safety blitz hey I've got call
it a shot
yes calling it a couple times and he was
right my only you know advice if I would
give to unsolicited sense is that with
all of these sets that he's seeing terms
like cross dog you know never for people
who are not X's and O's geeks you know
it confuses and that's why Collinsworth
is as great as he is and Aikman is is as
great as he is is they don't you know
you you could still be a casual fan and
understand the style of play that is
being shown and having it described
without you know confusing people with
very difficult football terms but mm-hm
I thought he was great I really I really
enjoyed him Rich Eisen NFL Network host
the Rich Eisen show following this one
on DIRECTV's audience Network channel
239 Ricardo it's good
- d/p thank you buddy well take care
buddy let's rejoice the Dan Patrick show
weekday mornings on audience